le sam avec françois bayrou bonjour a
vous tous je suis ravi de vous retrouver
françois bayrou je rappelle que vous
êtes président donc du modem et maire de
pau 1 première question françois
hollande avait un statut est ce qu'il ya
une stature depuis un mois en tout cas
il a montré dans les événements qu'il
est qu'il avait fait face avec la
dimension nécessaire aux impératifs
tragique un moment et donc ça c'est
c'est indiscutablement un acquis mais
c'est un acquis pour nous c'est un
acquis pour le climat politique générale
dans le pays
je pense les deux alors je suis
minoritaire quand je dis ça
tous les observateurs vous ne
l'entendiez tabarre 10 bon c'était un
moment c'était médiatique et pas un
politique
je pense pour ma part que beaucoup de
français ont eu le sentiment dans cette
période qu'ils avaient quelque chose à
défendre que ça net keane que nous
n'étions pas un peuple comme les autres
où un peuple qui se résume simplement à
une collection de personnes et de
communautés qui vivent ensemble on a
mesuré dans ses moments encore une fois
tragiques que la france c'était quelque
chose que loyers s'est passablement que
ce soit simplement une courbe du chômage
les problèmes économiques ça n'est pas
seulement et connaît aussi malraux camus
une sorte de ré plus et plus simplement
l'idée que nous défendons ici des noix
une liberté quelque chose qui nous rend
d'une certaine manière rebelles à
l'égard de tous ceux qui voudraient nous
soumettre un grandes questions
concernant le chômage tout le monde a
remarqué lors de cette conférence de
presse qu effectivement il a beaucoup
parlé de politique étrangère il va
animer cet après midi guillaume tabard
accepte alors qu'ils feraient les
annonces concernant la dissuasion
nucléaire mais enfin la situation
économique étranger que je voudrais
prendre un seul exemple qui ce qui vous
concerne un peu ces histoires du
boulanger près de près de dakhla
saint-paul-lès-dax monsieur à une
vingtaine de personnes meilleur ouvrier
de france
il travaille sept jours sur sept il se
fécondent à
et par l'inspection du travail qui lui
ordonne de fermer est ce qu'on n'est pas
c'est pas l'exemple typique du délire
française ben oui on est dans quelque
chose qui est inacceptable
au fond qu'est ce que les français
veulent ils veulent que bien sûr le
dimanche ne soit pas un jour comme les
autres et ils ont raison et en même
temps que laisser travailler
j'ai toujours été sur cette ligne et
deuxièmement ils veulent qu'on laisse
travailler ceux qui ont envie de
travailler alors eu davantage les petits
clé que les très gros vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est pas l'ouverture des
grandes surfaces le dimanche que les
gens attendaient au contraire je crois
que beaucoup d'entre la mode août
mais ce qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils
aiment c'est que un artisan commerçant
et boulanger il travaille toujours
depuis des années le dimanche matin la
question là c'est quelqu'un qui veut
travailler sept jours par semaine parce
qu'il à 25 salariés
donc les salariés tourne et tout d'un
coup c'est l'inspection du travail
cuillé stop on a ramé est condamné il y
à il ya très souvent des abus de cet
ordre et j'emploie le mot abus c'est à
dire que on a l'impression que le que la
volonté de créer la volonté de vivre la
volonté de faire naître des eaux des
emplois nouveaux
peut-être des richesses un nouvel que
cette volonté là est mal vue en france
et qu'elle est sanctionné et on a et
qu'il y à une perpétuelle suspicion vous
savez à 1-1 douteux inquisitoriale
souvent sur ceux qui travaillent
il suffit de il suffirait de laisser
cela agir et vous soutenez votre grand
druide je le soutiens il suffirait de
laisser seul à agir pour qu'une grande
partie des potentialités française de ce
que la france peut faire de ses moyens
de ceux de sa richesse intellectuelle
tout d'un coup on recrée de l'emploi et
de la richesse que françois hollande
venait de
deux souligné la stature ces derniers
temps est une sorte de schizophrènes qui
ne voudrait pas voir la situation
économique du pays
pascal à droite tout le monde lui tire
dessus en expliquant que finalement rien
n'a changé je cite depuis quelques
matins et dernières statistiques
eurostat
parfois elles sont quand même importante
nous sommes 28 dans l'union européenne
ya 24 pays dont le chômage baisse 24 sur
28 la france non ben c'est tout à fait
vrai
ce qui était frappant dans la conférence
de presse de françois hollande entre ces
positions qui sont juste je crois en
politique étrangère ce qui était
frappant c'est que pour le reste il a
décidé de ne plus rien changé comme si
la loi macron mettait enfin les mesures
innombrables et inégalée des et qui au
fond ne ne change pas fondamentalement
la situation
ces mesures innombrables et inégale
comme si c'était la fin de la réforme
et puis d'un autre côté des squales a vu
ce que vous avez ce matin que cette
politique économique depuis le début est
un échec du point de vue des
institutions
je finis je reviens à votre question
donc rien changé plus rien changer en
politique économique de substantielles
et puis ensuite du point de vue des
institutions de la manière dont nous
vivons notre vie politique qui dieu sait
est catastrophique ne put rien changé
non plus dire parce que dire je ne
changerais que si j'obtiens un consensus
absolu c'est une manière détournée de
dire qu'on ne changera président
notamment sur votre mairie chèque il y à
il y a des choses absolument essentiels
qui vont un jour se retourner contre la
démocratie française
la volonté ou le refus de voir les
courants différents du pays être
représenté dans notre vie publique et
notamment parlement le fait qu'on écarte
de la représentation en france très
grand nombre de français
c'est à dire
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche et
le centre ce qui fait plus de 50% des
français cela c'est au bout du compte
une menace sur la manière dont nous
vivons notre vie publique je ne vous
pousse pas à sanctionner la politique de
france hollande mais la question se pose
elle s'impose pour les gens de la gauche
considère qu'il est responsable de la
gauche de la gauche considère qu'il est
responsable de la situation économique
tragique en matière d'emploi du pays est
évidemment pour l'essentiel des gens de
droite
tous les leaders de droite qui
considèrent aujourd'hui est donc ce
matin je pose la question si vous a pas
entendu là-dessus qu'ils considèrent que
cette politique est un échec complet
je dirais pas ça je pense que les 15
dernières années de la politique
française ont été une incapacité à
rendre au pays
le ca nécessaire liberté et sa
nécessaire simplicité on est tous jours
séparent langue c'est sheeran
sarkozy hollande oui ces deux années
ces quinze années et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je si souvent marquée des
positions différentes où on a été
incapable non seulement incapable
incapable de changer mais incapable de
nommer des choses qu'il fallait changer
quand le chômage pendant huit neuf mois
j'ai un peu de mémoire et a été
stabilisé même commencé à redescendre
c'était le cas à la fin des à la fin des
années 90 et au début des années 2000
dit ça et puis ça a recommencé à fléchir
mais rien de thierry breton de mélo nice
de même qu'à fléchi notre commerce
extérieur
parce que nous avons un commerce
extérieur qui n'a cessé de se dégrader
et contrairement aux apparences il se
dégrade encore parce que le prix du
verbe en fait rien prix du pétrole ben
parce que il suffit pour françois
hollande ne fait-il rien de ce qu'il est
pas idiot je vous ai je crois qu'il ya
deux choses la première c'est qu'on ne
on n'ose pas faire et la deuxième c'est
qu'on ne voit pas bien ce qu'il faudrait
faire
or à mes yeux ça bien marché du travail
flexibilité
diminution de la pression fiscale c'est
entre traiter la question du contrat de
travail
traiter la question d'un droit social
dans le droit du travail qui est un
labyrinthe où tout le monde me dire mais
en tout cas
faisons le cessons de le dire et faisons
le ça sera le meilleur service à rendre
au pays et à tous ceux qui veulent le
faire vivre
question est-ce que vous avez sauté sur
votre chaise quand vous avez vu alain
juppé au conseil national de l'ump se
faire huer quand il a prononcé un mot
ancien hacker modèle dans la salle oui
bon il s'est fait huer en prononçant le
nom de modem il s'est fait huer le
président c'est vous qui haïssez fait
huer en prononçant le nom ou le mot de
déçus de hollande parce que le
sectarisme l'esprit partisan c'est un
des plus hauts degrés de la bêtise et
donc le l'idée qu' on pourrait gagner
tout seul et qu'il est impossible de
parler avec des gens qui ont des
positions différentes de soi sans fil et
la table est une secte l'ump telle
qu'elle existe actuellement est une
secte je sais vous qu'elle empêche
j'essaie de choisir mes mots je lis le
sectarisme
j'ai dit que le sectarisme militants et
ça arrive souvent donc ces deux sexes
dans tous les partis
le sectarisme militants et l'esprit
partisan celui qui considère qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule chose qui compte c'est son
étiquette et que je commence à très bien
parce que oui vous traite de traître et
vous vous dites maintenant je veux pas
les traité de sectaire mais je n'ai pas
l'intention d'entrer dans le duel des
insultes c'est pas que je saurai pas
années d'insultés selon lui ce qui vous
plaît
oui et ce n'est pas seulement que ce
n'est pas non plus que parfois je
n'aurais pas envie je pense que c'est
mauvais je pense que c'est pas le bon
garçon il a la bonne habitude mais ça
n'est pas la bonne et que je vais vous
dire ce qu'ils ne supportent pas qu'il
ait anigo lazare les ceux qui sifflent
et font siffler et mûri longtemps
prononcé de son nom ce qui sifflaient
franc sifflé qu'est-ce qui ne supporte
pas il ne supporte pas qu'on soit libre
supporte pas d'avoir en face de soi ou à
côté de soi une
volonté et une indépendance ses voisins
de la soul a fait perdre quand ces gars
que vous et marine le pen est
responsable sa défaite
eh bien ils arrêtent pas envie vous
applaudit le parle de nicolas sarkozy ça
sous les charges bas à l'applaudir et je
ne cherche pas être applaudie par lui et
je ne cherche pas non plus à entrer dans
des débats polémique est ridicule
le responsable de la défaite de nicolas
sarkozy c'est nicolas sarkozy
c'était le cas en 2012 et c'est le cas
encore aujourd'hui les difficultés qui
sont les siennes
elles viennent d'une certaine manière de
prendre la politique
est ce cette espèce de de volonté
d'opposer des gens et de les faire huer
et de les faire siffler c'est une partie
de ce que les français rejettent chez
lui parce que on a besoin d'homme d'état
pas d'homme politique ses partenaires
parvenaient qu'à laisser finir mais on a
besoin d'homme d'état et de femme d'état
on a besoin de gens pour qui au fond
avec un parcours politique qui leur
donne une certaine expérience
on considère il considère que l'idée
qu'ils se font de l'intérêt général est
plus importante que des intérêts
particuliers au nombre desquels les
intérêts partisans
ballard est double l'esprit de parti
c'est le contraire de l'amour du pays
le l'amour du pays le patriotisme
appelons le comme on veut ça nécessite
de rassembler les gens de rassembler ses
concitoyens de faire que tout dans le
quizz et une idée de l'avenir qu'ils
puissent partager et qu'on dise bon au
fond vous guillaume durand vous
avaient voté hollande et puis un autre à
voter sarkozy et un troisième a voté je
ne sais qui bayrou un autre mais ça
n'est pas pour autant que nous sommes
condamnés à jamais à ne pas travailler
ensemble où elles n'ont jamais travaillé
ensemble caisse a failli renverser votre
café jeu oui ça s'est passé est tombé
dites moi c'est bien gentil et votre
histoire justement d'unités mais vous
venez de faire lentilles portrait
d'alain juppé et l'homme responsable
c'est toujours celui vous soutenez ben
oui j'ai de l'estimé pour alain juppé je
vois pas pourquoi je le devais laisser
pas le soutien c'est un soutien jusqu'au
bout guillaume durand il ya quarante
cinq secondes il ya un dernier sujet qui
est important vous me laissez parler les
deux grandes soirées chaudes à lui deux
sujets pardonnez ma branche aînée vous
parlez de cette union est ce
rassemblement mais enfin alain juppé
s'est prononcé clairement contre le
front national
il ya 30% des français qui votent pour
lui de vous nous parlez d'une union mais
pas une union - tran à leurs jupes et
plus le front national à nanterre ben
oui je pense que le pays a besoin de
personnalités qu'il entraîne et le
rassemblent et les personnalités qui au
contraire le déchirent organise les
affrontements en leur ca ne vont pas
pour moi dans le bon sens premièrement
deuxièmement vous avez parfaitement
raison de souligner que le fait que 30 %
des français se trouvent en dehors du
jeu est un drame pour le pays et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je dis il est
indispensable
moi qui ai toujours combattu leurs idées
ou leurs obsessions je ne sais pas ce
qu'il faut dire que ceux qui votent pour
le front national soient représentés
dans les assemblées et c'est pourquoi un
changement de la loi électorale pour
obtenir une loi électorale
enfin juste est une nécessité de mieux
intégrer ça n'arriverait pas et bien si
ça n'arrive pas c'est la faute c'est une
responsabilité et une faute de la part
de ceux qui se devrait de ce fait à rien
et qui s'y sont engagés siens
soutiendrait a ajouté mais de vous
rappeler que françois lanthier engagé à
ça a été dansé dans ses engagements de
campagne électorale mais vous vous
soutiendrez jusqu'au bout alain juppé
mais je vous dis je vous fait un peu
tendez le croyez cette veille est simple
c'est très simple oui je pense qu'il va
aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la prime est
où là la candidature là il a choisi de
il a choisi le mécanisme de la primaire
c'est pas le choix que j'aurais fait il
le sait et vous et vous le savez est
cependant je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui mérite qu'on le soutienne et avec
qui il ne serait pas difficile pour le
courant de pensée que je représente de
s'entendre pour que la france change
voilà exactement les choses merci
françois bayrou jeu rien s'ils avaient
une présidente du modem
et merde pour